Tom Hardy's back at it again people Tom
Hardy teases spider-man and vet him too
again let's see what this is about
cosmic wonder told me he was gonna be
doing this video I told him specifically
once this video is out I'm gonna be
reacting to it buddy
let's do it
[Music]
[Music]
how's it going everybody its Lauren
welcome back to my channel to cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
relating to high war and today we're
going to be talking about venom two
because Tom Hardy is at it again
doing his usual posting a photo and then
instantly deleting love it love it
notifications on take screenshots and we
actually see the post County knows that
people do this that's what he only keeps
the post up for about a minute because
he knows everybody's going to see it
anyways up the photo his fun little way
of teasing us and recently he knows that
man could be in venom too because it
looks rip down his new post if you're
new be sure to subscribe to stay up to
date on all things relating to venom to
also so you can in deleted it was a
venom basically biting spider-man in
half it was a pretty brutal photo at
least we thought it was a brutal photo
until he posted a new one now this photo
is by ultra raw 26 you can find him on
Instagram but Tom Hardy shared his photo
on his Instagram and this photo of venom
basically biting the head off of
spider-man NASA forever truly see this
obviously they're not going to kill off
spider-man and vanaya what Tom Hardy
does keep teasing spider-man and it's
interesting that this comes along with
the recent news of Sony's new name for
their spider-man universe if you missed
the news about this the official
spider-man far from home page on Twitter
tweeted join spider-man and all his
friends while you swing through all the
films from the spider-man universe of
characters not exactly the best name but
unfortunately that wasn't the true name
that Sony dubbed it the actual name for
the universe according to IGN who
reached out to Sony is Sony Pictures at
universe of Marvel characters
but Sony is making a very specific
statement here by including Marvel in
the title they want everybody to know
that spider-man is a part of their
universe and this is also why they put
vulture in the Morbius trailer because
the universe want to write Kevin Feige
have said so of course the big question
now is is spider-man Tom Hollands
spider-man going to appear in venom to
Tom Hardy has now teased it a couple of
times and Sony has now officially
changed their name oh boy people
associate their universe with the Marvel
Universe so it definitely seems like
they could be preparing us to see
spider-man in venom to us I personally
would love this to happen and if it did
happen
I would definitely freak out but let me
know what you think would you like to
see spider-man in venom to let me know
what you think in the comments down
below don't forget to give the video a
like and subscribe so you don't miss out
on anything relating to venom 2 for live
updates you can follow me on Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof oh my goodness Thomas the
Hardy getting everyone hard the Spidey
Hardy for Spidey you think Johnny think
he's just trolling us I mean I think
that there's something to this but yeah
I think he's teasing us I agree with
Warren basically I'd be very surprised
if venom killed off any Spider Man in
any way as gory as that Hartley I am
hoping that maybe these are hinting at a
harder core more r-rated territory
because I mean some Hardy tweets a lot
of pictures I know it's not likely but
at the same time these two spider-man
images have both been gory this is one
he's Goering spider-man's head off in
the previous one he's biting him in half
and there's blood spraying so I'm mostly
curious as to why he's posting such
graphic spider-man images because you
know his teases towards spider-man seem
to have this flavor but I am really
excited for the idea that we might get
an appearance and as much as Sony is
dogged upon for their involvement in
Marvel's properties and as much as I
think everybody would like to see
spider-man and everything Sony owns
revert back to Marvel proper I do kind
of have an openness to that because of
the collaboration factor and the fact
we will have clearly a different side of
the universe to look at that has its own
flavor that's associated with it so
especially on the heels of the Sony
Pictures universe of Marvel characters
announcement to which he brought up
Kevin Feige in the video and half my
mind went I wonder if they wanted to
call it the spider-man universe of
characters and then Marvel would like
new we got to separate you guys from us
so that people know who's making what I
think he's having a good laugh but I
think there's something to whatever he's
doing
I don't think Kevin Feige wanted the
Marvel name in there at all I highly
doubt he wanted it in there I could
assume two things here one is Tom
Hardy's either trolling just to get a
laugh Tom Hardy just seems like the kind
of guy who would do something like that
I don't know the kind personally but
from everything I've heard about it just
seems like something you would do or it
could actually see it being him trying
to help out with pushing to get a Tom
Halden appearance or a cameo or
something like that inside of the like
venom three at the most obviously Kevin
Feige knows that fans probably want it
right but if there's enough of an
outpour enough of an outcry of people
going with Tom Hardy talking about it
Tom Holland in the past saying that he
would like that to occur and also with
Sony going out of their way to make the
the spunk just sounds like Sputnik to me
is you're Sputnik who and I hear that
Bri VA ssin what is spider-man universe
of Marvel characters what is this Sony
Pictures universe of Marvel care that's
just the weirdest way more obscene an
acronym if you're in the UK I'd imagine
so
and with this image that warm put up
here from the spider-man far from home
Twitter complete your spider-man movie
collection this limited prime video
offer
it's like Sony really seems to be going
out of their way to show us specifically
the audience that Tom Hollands
spider-man belongs to us meaning we can
put Tom Holland and venom in the same
movie together I just want to keep my
focus right now on carnage and venom
going toe-to-toe if you want to know
more my thoughts on this matter
we covered the last video Warren did the
first time Tom rdt smile
and venom yeah I would just want it to
be a cameo at the end if anything like a
post-credits scene or something like
that
I think these images that Tom Hardy's
posting are more about having spider-man
and venom verse each other and this is
just a venom attitude to have that he's
gonna bite his head off you know
yeah it's bound to happen it's going now
yeah I think there's one thing we can't
deny is that it's in the works I'm sure
there's plenty of discussions that's
just you know Kevin Feige is he's mainly
just concerned about the MCU if anything
he just wants to make sure the Tom
Holland character Peter Parker's and
whoever else is crossing over is not
tampered with that messes with the MCU
specifically venom doesn't bite
spider-man's head off before he's
supposed to appear in the next event you
they wouldn't have venom kill off
spider-man at any degree maybe some
alternate universe spider-man though
anyway
warning exponents video together dude
look forward to these from you all the
time my friend guys and subscribe the
cost of one or make sure to do so as
soon as you can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification but I'll
get notified never got a video up last
but not least it's up Eric Horstman and
Anissa Oliv these are our two top
patrons and also our top contributors
and our live streams as well Eric lives
in Atlanta has got a real rejects tattoo
Anissa lives in Texas and I just thought
it would be fun if one day these two met
each other considering that they are our
top contributors Eric works at a hotel
let's do this
interior Marriott hotel afternoon Eric
Horstman late 90s but sexier than men in
their 50s works as a receptionist behind
the counter played by me Anissa liver 18
hot AF but also wildly mature approaches
with a suitcase how may I help you yes I
have a reservation under Anissa Oliver
Anissa
Oliver as in my main competitor for
number-one fan of the real rejects Erik
why do I know that name there of course
when you go selfies stupid [ __ ]
[Laughter]
that was weird
oh we do like weird what brings you to
Atlanta I'm meeting John Humphrey at the
gas station is that the one off route 98
yeah how'd you know I've been to many
glory holes down there oh don't judge me
I'm not hmm your ID says you're a
pescetarian weird thing to put down here
yeah well I think it's important to
spread the word I do too that's why I'm
a vegan so you might have fish and eggs
but I don't it's not a competition oh I
know I know
random thought I often house and look
after many animals so not only am i
making sure i'm not contributing in the
food eating department but i physically
help out animals too good for you
it's weird I also had a random thought
about how helpful I am I get it you
contribute more during their live
streams no not that I mean yeah that's
true but I was thinking I actually work
in an ER yeah well I got a real Rejects
tattoo yeah well John's gonna put me up
at the gas station damn Greg he was
supposed to meet me at the glory hole
according to this your name means
eternal ruler yeah yeah it does just
like how I'm the eternal ruler of the
fan base or the real rejects what does
your name mean something stupid like
like I don't know think good-natured or
something yeah that's exactly what it
means
oh that's a good name your ID here says
you're from Texas that's right
friendship what that's our motto
I thought your motto would be Trump
supporter god no I voted for Bernie what
me too I'm a supporter of the me to
movement also no way me too huh maybe we
should consider putting the competition
to the side and being friends I agree
Eric pulls out a ball roll whiskey a
shot of tequila and a glass of vodka he
downs all the liquor is instantly drunk
when he puffs away at a cigarette say
I've never been with a woman before
before you meet up with John what do you
say we get you some practice with me and
one of them galore you know eric is
arrested for sexual harassment plus
drunken disorderly conduct while
receiving zero unemployment benefits
from his work but he still remained
pledged to the Rio rejects it needs to
met me at that gas station
you